Trey,
my daddy Joe Rogan podcast by night all
day now.
There's so much going on.
Supplement Scott,
you have to make sure you put it in the
research and investigation.
Speaking in your body.
I poke and did you see that picture of
Travis Brown's finger knuckle deep into
from silver dooms eyeball?
He didn't even say anything in the fight
right there for doom.
I don't remember seeing [inaudible] I
call home or anything on that.
I don't remember.
I did see that jump,
that jump psychic in the beginning.
You get the hand on his trainer res.
It was a cool without that fight there
was cool,
cool,
cool fight.
Well it was,
it was Obama to me to see Travis fight
like that because I remember travis
earlier in his career was just to look
at that picture.
That is fucking insane.
Esther,
Esther Lynn from all elbows on
Instagram,
put this picture up and um,
she's an mma,
a photographer.
She takes awesome pictures to an awesome
picture.
And this is insane.
I mean,
it is literally knuckled deep in his
eyeball.
It just,
it's hard to look at,
man.
It's just,
Oh my God.
That though too.
Right?
There's middle knuckle.
It's like this finger has disappeared in
the eyeball.
I don't remember him stopping or saying
I poke or anything.
I don't remember either.
Let's focus.
But there was a bad one earlier in the
night with Jimmy Rivera and a Uriah.
Yeah.
That was a bad one.
And Jimmy Rivera after the fights that
he couldn't see,
you still couldn't see.
He's like,
he said he couldn't tell what color
things were out of his right eye.
Yeah.
Fucking I pokes man.
Pride gloves.
Huh?
You got to redesign the gloves.
A little bit of a car to turn there and
that opened all the way.
Sorry.
No,
I think you're right.
Most of the time,
this is what I do.
I obsess about Marsha lives to making
things better.
Someone's got to do something because
the way things are going,
we're just so many guys are getting,
I go so many guys getting damaged
eyeballs.
It's just,
it's not worth it,
man.
And it seems like we're waiting for
something terrible to happen.
You know,
like look at Michael Bisping,
I dunno.
Bisping's came from a kick though.
I feel like it might have come from
vittores kick.
What was it that,
or was it in practice?
I don't know.
Do you think it was in practice?
I think he detached his retina a couple
times,
so I think that's why it is the way it
is.
I think he's heard it multiple times and
it was kind of where it,
cause it's not completely fixed.
I think they fixed it enough to where he
can fight and then when he's done
fighting they'll probably fix is I
completed these what it seems like,
well what they did is they stuck oil in
his eye.
I don't understand it,
but one of his eyeballs apparently has
oil in it that's protecting the retina.
So that's why one of his eyeballs is
black,
like you know.
Yeah.
I was wondering what was going on with
desires.
That's why.
Yeah.
One is black and one is his original
aicar,
which I'm not sure what it is,
but it's very strange looking,
but it's just,
he's a fucking savage.
I mean he didn't even consider retiring.
He's like,
Hey,
yeah,
stick some oil in there.
Let's get going whenever I reckon do put
an eyepatch on.
Let's do this.
Got To get back to the gym mate.
He does push it.
That guy comes to fight.
He such an Amo.
Michael Bisping is the middleweight
champion of the world.
And who saw that coming?
He did.
Yep.
I seen that opening in,
uh,
in,
luke rockhold to instagram videos
leading up to the fight.
I seen the same thing his trainer saw.
Really?
Yeah.
He just leaned it back.
He was telling me weeks before the fight
that things he was doing while he's
hitting meds,
dropping his right hand all the time
with his left cross and kind of leaning
back and kind of shoulder roll and,
and whatnot.
And Duane called it out a couple of
weeks before the fight that he saw
openings.
You know,
he didn't say he was gonna get knocked
out with it,
but he saw some openings there,
you know,
is there,
I mean that's it.
It's pretty simple.
You can see where the openings are on
that one for sure.
And,
uh,
I remember after bisbing caught him and
his trainer point Adam,
and I'm not quite sure what he said and
left,
but he was for sure.
I was saying,
I could see,
I told you I told you like that one.
Yeah.
Yes.
He's a good boxing coach.
He understands the game.
I got respect for that guy.
Um,
but it's cool to see something you've
trained multiple times come out and
actually work.
And then when the fight and then the
title fight.
Ooh,
that's,
that's nice.
That's rewarding.
That's what I wanted to bring up to you.
What did you think about the Travis
Browne?
Fabrizio over doing five where we're
travis called time.
He got his finger jammed for Breeshia,
threw a punch and Travis Travis has
finger apparently broke and there's some
photos of it now online.
It was,
it's fucking nasty.
Like,
shows you how tough travis is that he
continued with his finger was smashed
and it was a compound fracture where the
bone broke through the skin.
That's one picture,
but there's some even better ones that
he released today.
Well,
you could see it,
uh,
after the fight.
It was a nasty break,
but so it was a weird thing where for
resale through this punch and he threw
like one of those chocolate dell style
over hands.
It come over the top and it landed on
the fingers of Travis and snapped one of
his finger.
So Travis calls time,
which you really can't do is look at my
fingers fucked up calls time like,
oh wow.
Scroll up though.
When you see it.
The actual opening.
Yeah.
Here comes the boom.
He says time out,
right?
Yeah.
Given James said he cannot do that.
I missed I guess Marie Smith.
Did they stop?
Did they go?
Sorry.
Oh,
that's right.
You did that boss.
Yeah.
You did that in a fight.
I,
yeah,
I get,
but if Maurice,
no,
I did.
I liked that.
Yeah.
I kicked him in the head and then I,
I got excited and wanted to give him
another kick in the head,
but I slip and a fall on the ground and
Maurice wants to jump on top of me and I
put my head up.
I say,
wait,
he stops and I'm getting up,
and I go,
thank you.
That's good closure.
That's an adjacent trick.
Yeah.
And another one to help,
fairly funny,
anybody with a Jason de Lucia.
I dropped her with this liver shot,
right?
And then I walked over to him and you
see what I'm doing as stretch my arm
above me and I wave with my hand and you
see him look it up to my head,
and then I live or kick him again.
I just put my hand up and say,
yeah,
look at this.
And it looks,
he actually look there.
That's fine.
That's good composure.
Right?
We actually use that stuff all the time.
The bird,
the bird.
So there's mastercard,
master Tong.
He's,
uh,
my,
my first striking coach.
Okay.